this factory manufactures hundreds of
thousands of televisions and air
conditioners a month
but now it's in the process of turning
into a different kind of operation
this one particular line can manufacture
three thousand phones in an eight hour
shift
the indian tech and appliances company
micromax is pivoting to smartphones
because of politics
geopolitical situation especially
between china and u.s it is a great
opportunity for us
[Applause]
the trade war between china and the u.s
has pushed foreign tech companies to
relocate part of their production
outside of china
india wants to be their next best option
it has a large and cheap workforce plus
the government has been offering
generous subsidies
while also promising a more open
regulatory regime
before the trade war india ranked third
behind vietnam and china when it came to
the global production of mobile phones
but with increasing tree tensions india
is now in second place
and starting to chip away at china's
market share
if china loses india gains there's no
other country that has the
infrastructure that we have
and the manpower that we have that's our
biggest asset
and we're hoping to cash in on that
[Applause]
india's plan to build a competitive
smartphone supply chain to china's
is a technical and logistical feat
putting to the test whether india can
become the world's next smartphone
superpower
[Music]
india isn't starting from scratch sunil
june is the head of products at micromax
and says the company
has been making home appliances since
2000.
assembling or manufacturing a display of
a mobile phone and tv
shares this similar technology and
experience the first android one phone
from micromax
in the early years the company was
actually in the smartphone business
designing and putting them together in
the country with roughly 90
of the components coming from china can
be furiously fast
but micromax's phone business collapsed
once cheaper chinese products flooded
india
now the company is dusting off their
design skills and ramping up its
manufacturing capabilities to get back
in the game
june says a big technical challenge was
the motherboard which holds all the
smartphones key components
same setup same machine same tools this
is led tv motherboard whereas this is a
set of four motherboards for mobile
phone
but the motherboard is just one of more
than 700 components that go into a
smartphone
and micromax has had to convince other
indian companies to help produce those
parts
for more than two decades pankaj
shakdeva has been producing batteries
for electric fans
remote controls and mobile phones this
was actually a natural
extension of what we were doing because
we were already in the battery business
as
traders his challenge was to create a
battery that would power a smartphone
for up to two days
so now this is the finished product that
you see here it's kept at a high
temperature
for 72 hours to make sure that nothing
goes wrong with the battery and a high
temperature is on
shakhtar says he now wants to focus on
smartphone batteries
going forward smartphone is the future
so definitely we have to be ready for
that market as well
we're hoping that this ecosystem can
grow much better domestically
not just to cater to india but to cater
to the global market as well
in just six months micromax proved that
it could design and put together its own
smartphone
it's now rolling out what it calls made
in india phones
this speedy buildup in india's
smartphone production capacity
has caught the attention of tech giants
samsung closed all its manufacturing
facilities in china by 2019
and opened one of its largest factories
in india
even apple's supplier foxconn is now
producing iphones in the country
so five trillion dollar economical dream
b
the government is also adding an
incentive to push tech companies to grow
their business in the country
so it's offering to pay them up to six
percent of the value of the additional
mobile phones they sell each year
this is a fairly new expansion that we
have done it took us two weeks to expand
to this level
micromax claims that 60 of the value of
its phone components are currently
sourced from india
and with the government's help the
company expects to get to one hundred
percent
in three years that is something which
will still
take some time five to ten years at
least
varun mishra is an analyst who's been
watching the indian smartphone industry
since the start of the trade war
he doesn't think it's possible for a
company like micromax to source a
majority of the components locally right
now
because india's tech industry as a whole
still has a long way to go
the value added by the components which
are sourced locally
is is at 12 these components and these
manufacturers
you know they require a very very
sophisticated infrastructure a very very
uh you know robust policy framework
so while the country is able to produce
simple components like battery chargers
or the exterior of phones
it hasn't yet tackled the challenge of
building a domestic and robust supply
chain for more sophisticated technology
like led screens or memory chips
and a majority of these components are
still coming from china
even the raw material that goes into the
batteries produced in shakdeva's
factories
they control the lithium supplies
globally
that is where we don't have a choice but
we depend on them as of now
we're hoping that over the years we can
change that
and it already is india has signed
agreements with australia and bolivia to
tap their large lithium reserves
but until india can fully peel away from
chinese suppliers
its smartphone ambitions are under
threat
for example a border dispute in the
himalayas between china and india during
the summer
sparked boycotts of chinese products
[Music]
indian customs officials started to
manually check tech components imported
from china
that ended up stopping micromax's
production for months and this shortage
of parts
came on top of the impact of the
coronavirus pandemic
kovite 19 has had a lot of impacts in
the whole
supply chain the procurement of
components became very very difficult
the economy was hit a lot especially
unorganized economies like india there
was a lot of
job losses so in order for india to
achieve its goal of becoming the world's
smartphone leader
it's going to have to deal with problems
at home first